method works differently and it only works for CSS codes. In this method, we don't actually perform the syndrome measurements on the encoded quantum
states in the circuit that we're trying to run, but instead we intentionally propagate errors to a workspace system
and then measure that system and classically detect errors. This figure shown here shows how to do this for X errors in which case the workspace
cubits are initially set to an encoding of a plus state. So this is basically a
transversal implementation of a C not gate which should do nothing because the target is in a plus state. But if there
were X errors in the top cubits, they'll propagate down to the lower system and they'll be detected. There's also a similar method for detecting Z errors
and that isn't shown here. There's also a related method known as canel error correction first proposed by Manny Canil
and it's based on teleportation rather than a transversal C not and that allows it to work for arbitrary stabilizer
codes and not just CSS codes.
The last thing that I'll discuss in this lesson is a very important theorem known as the threshold theorem. Here's a somewhat informal
statement of the theorem. It says that if we have any quantum circuit having n gates where n can be as large as we like, then it's
possible to implement that circuit with high accuracy using a noisy quantum circuit provided that the level of noise
is below a certain threshold value that's independent of n. And moreover, it isn't too expensive to do this in the
sense that the size of the noisy circuit required is on the order of n times some constant power of the logarithm of
n. To state the theorem more formally requires being specific about the noise model, which I won't do in this lesson.
It can for instance be proved for the independent stochastic noise model that I mentioned earlier where errors occur
independently at each possible location in the circuit with some probability that's strictly smaller than this threshold value. But it can also be
proved for more general noise models where there can be correlations among errors. Now, this is a theoretical
result and the typical way that it's proved doesn't necessarily translate to something that we would actually do in practice, but it's nevertheless a very
important theorem in practical terms. And the reason for this is that it basically says that there's no fundamental barrier to performing
quantum computations using noisy components.
As long as the error rate for these components is below this threshold value, they can be used to build reliable quantum circuits of arbitrary
size. Another way to say it is that if the theorem wasn't true, it's hard to imagine large scale quantum computing
ever becoming a reality. There's a lot of technical details involved in formal proofs of this theorem, which I won't attempt to
communicate. But I will try to explain the basic idea at a high level. And I'll also try to loosely connect the basic
idea to what we might expect to happen in practice. So let's suppose that this is our circuit. It's the same circuit that
we've been talking about for the entire lesson. But again, we can imagine that our circuit is significantly larger and more complicated than this. We'd like to
implement this circuit, but all of our components are noisy. And assuming we're using the independent stochcastic noise
model just for simplicity, there's some probability P with which errors occur independently at each possible location.
If the circuit was significantly larger than the reciprocal of this probability P, then we could be pretty sure that a
direct implementation of it wouldn't work correctly. So we go through all of the business of implementing the circuit
fall tolerantly as I've discussed up to this point in the lesson and we ask ourselves the question that I raised earlier which is are we making things
better or are we making things worse? Well if the probability P that represents the error probability for each of our components is too large then
this isn't going to help just like the 9Q short code doesn't help if the error probability is above 3 and a/4% or so.
In particular, we've now made the circuit larger. So there are a lot more locations where errors could strike.
However, if P is small enough, this is going to help. And what we'll effectively do is to reduce the error
probability for the logical computation that we're performing. So let's think about this in
just a little bit more detail. And to see the main ideas in as simple a setting as possible, let's suppose that we use the 7 cubit steam code for error
correction, which allows for the correction of up to one error per code block. So in order for a logical error
to occur in the original circuit, we'll have to have at least two errors falling into the same code block for our fault
tolerant implementation.
Keeping in mind that there are a lot of different ways to have two or more errors in the same code block, it can be argued that the probability of a logical
error at each location in the original circuit is at most C * P ^ 2 where C is a number that depends on the code and on
the gadgets that we use. But critically, it does not depend on the size of the original circuit.
So if P is smaller than the reciprocal of C which is the number that we can take as our threshold value then this
translates to a reduction in error. So our hard work in implementing the circuit fall tolerantly is paying
off. However this new error rate might still be too high for the entire circuit to work correctly. So we need to do
more. In practice a natural thing to do at this point is to choose a better code and better gadgets to drive the error
rate down to a point where the implementation is likely to work.
Theoretically speaking, a simple way to argue that this is possible is to concatenate. In other words, we think
about the fault tolerant implementation of the original circuit as a new logical circuit. And then we implement it fault
tolerantly. And then we do this again and again as many times as we need. And it turns out that this reduces the error
very quickly. And that's how the threshold theorem is typically proved on paper.
I'll give you just a very rough idea for how the error rate decreases leaving out the many technical details required to
prove this formally. We start with the error probability P for our original components. And if we implement the
circuit fall tolerantly, the error decreases by a factor of C * P. If we then treat our fault tolerant
implementation as a logical circuit and implement it fault tolerantly, we get a similar decrease in the error rate. But
if we think about the effective error rate for the original circuit, we find that it drops even further because now
we're replacing the error rate P by C * P ^ 2 because that's the effective error rate after the first level fault
tolerant implementation. Specifically, after just a little bit of algebra, we find that the error goes down to CP
cubed * P. And if we do it again, we now have an error rate of CP ^ 7 * P. And if